>> JACK: Hi. My name is Jack and I work on
the calendar application for Android. I'd
like to tell you about two features today
that I really like about the calendar application.
One is that you can have public calendars
on your phone. So, for example, if you forget
one Easter's, you can have the Christian holidays
on the phone. You can also have all the U.S.
holidays. And there are many other public
calendars that you can load. Another thing
I like is the auto-link feature. For example,
if you have a web URL imbedded in anywhere
in the text of the event, that URL is automatically
linked, so that if you select it, it will
take you to the browser and bring up that
web page. Likewise, if you have a phone number
and you select that phone number, it will
take you to the dialer where you can make
the call.